let's multiply four and three-fourths
times five and one-half and to do this i
like to turn each of these mixed numbers
into improper fractions remember an
improper fraction is a fraction where
the numerator is greater than or equal
to the denominator so let's do that to
turn this into an improper fraction four
and three-fourths four is the same thing
as sixteen over four
and then we're going to add another
three-fourth so let me take that one
step at a time so this part right over
here is the same thing as four plus
three fourths
four is the same thing as sixteen over
four
sixteen over four
plus three fourths
and so if i add these two i get nineteen
nineteen over four so four and three
fourths is the same thing as 19 over
four a kind of quicker way or a way that
would take less space to do that you'd
say four times four is sixteen plus
three is nineteen nineteen over four and
then let's do the same for five and one
halves
five and one halves is the same thing as
five plus
one half
five if i multiply it by two is the same
thing as ten halves
five is ten halves and then we're still
going to add plus one half
and then ten halves plus one half is 11
halves and once again a kind of faster
way of doing it you could have said 2
times 5 is 10 plus 1 is 11. 11 halves
and now we can multiply they're both
improper fractions and so this is going
to be equal to the numerator is going to
be 19 times 11 19 times 11 and the
denominator is 4 times 2 which we can do
in our head that is just going to be 8.
and 19 times 11 you could do it in your
head you could say 19 times 10 this is
what my head is doing 19 times 10 gets
us to 190 and then 19 times 11 is going
to be 19 more than that so then i would
just add another 19 and get us to 209
if that makes no sense to you we could
just multiply it out we could just say
19
times 11 1 times 19 is 19 and then we
put a zero here because we're
essentially now multiplying 10 times 19.
so 1 times 19 is another 19. once again
it's really 10 times 19 is 190. we add
we get 9 we get a 10 and then we get 209
again so this part right over here is
209 over 8. and that is the right answer
but we've written it as an improper
fraction now we can convert it back to a
mixed number so we want to convert 209
over 8 to a mixed number that's the same
thing as 209 divided by 8. so let's just
divide eight into two hundred and nine
eight doesn't go into two it does go
into twenty two times two times eight is
sixteen we subtract twenty minus sixteen
is four
bring down the 9
8 goes into 49 six times 6 times 8 is 48
subtract we end up with a remainder of
1. so 209 over 8 or 209 divided by 8 is
the same thing as 26 so this is equal to
26 and you have a remainder of one so 26
and one over eight 26 and one over eight
and one over eight and we are done